Ausländer die hier arbeiten Deutsch
sprechen und gut integriert sind die
sollen in Zukunft schneller in Länder
werden die SPD will die Frist zur
Einbürgerung verkürzen Deutschland
attraktiver machen besonders auch für
Fachkräfte und Menschen die hier lange
leben die dann auch zum Beispiel wählen
lassen erst Integration dann
Staatsbürgerschaft so waren die die
cdu/csu und auch die FDP gibt sich
durchaus kritisch Streit um Einbürgerung
wer bekommt den deutschen Pass unser
Thema in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ja reden wir über die neuen Pläne
der bundesinnenministerin mit diesen
Gästen ich begrüße ganz herzlich gutes
dann Yüksel von der SPD sie ist
stellvertretende migrationspolitische
Sprecherin seit 2013 im Bundestag ihr
Wahlkreis ist in Mönchengladbach und sie
kam als Achtjährige aus der Türkei nach
Deutschland und herzlich willkommen
Andrea Lindholz von der CSU
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und dort
zuständig für recht innen vertriebene
Ausländer und Deutsche Minderheit eine
ganze Menge und herzlich willkommen
Marcel Fratzscher Präsident des
Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung und ich begrüße er
ist deutsch israelischer Psychologe
islamexperte und Geschäftsführer der
Mansour Initiative für
demokratie-förderung und
extremismusprävention ja reden wir über
diese neuen Vorschläge dass Einbürgerung
schneller gehen soll die Frist auf
verkürzt werden Frau Yüksel von 8 Jahre
auf 5 Jahre was bedeutet das was welche
Idee steckt dahinter warum will man das
machen naja die Verkürzung der Zeiten
von 8 auf 5 ist ja nicht das einzige
also die Menschen die hierher kommen die
hier leben sollen die wenn sie die
Voraussetzungen erfüllen das ist glaube
ich ganz wichtig das vergessen wir immer
wieder wenn sie die Voraussetzungen
erfüllen sollen sie eben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft beantragen können die
Kriterien sind nicht runtergesetzt die
bleiben und ich bin der Meinung dass
Menschen die schon seit Jahren hier
leben arbeiten Steuerzahlen eben die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft auch
bekommen sollten und ich denke das ist
ein sehr überfälliger
Reform wo wir schon seit Jahren darüber
diskutieren ich liebe seit 1970 in
Deutschland und seit 95 mache ich
Integrationspolitik Kommunalpolitik
jetzt Bundespolitik und die diese
Debatte führen wir immer wieder und ich
glaube das ist jetzt an der Zeit dass
wir da dran gehen sagen sie doch noch
mal kurz was die hauptvoraussetzungen
sind und deutscher Staatsbürger zu
werden sie müssen Lebensunterhalt
sicherstellen also nach jetzigen Stand
sie müssen acht Jahre unbefristen oder
einen Niederlassungserlaubnis haben
Lebensunterhalt sicherstellen sie müssen
deutsche Sprachkenntnisse nachweisen sie
müssen die also es gibt verschiedene
Kriterien die man erfüllen muss und dann
an diesen Kriterien wird ja nicht
gerüttelt was wir machen wollen ist eben
die Frist von acht auf fünf Jahre
runtersetzen damit eben Menschen
schneller die Möglichkeit haben sich in
Deutschland zu integrieren und auch eben
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zu
beantragen
findet das nicht richtig sie haben
gesagt die die Ampel will den deutschen
Pass offenbar veranschen wie meinen sie
das denn also zunächst mal freuen wir
uns über jeden der gut in Deutschland
integriert ist und sich dann auch
entscheidet die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft am anzunehmen es geht
nicht nur um die Herabsetzung der
Jahreszahlen das ist ein bisschen
vereinfacht sondern es geht um
verschiedene Komponenten es geht auch
darum dass die der Grundsatz der
Mehrstaatlichkeit eingeführt werden soll
das heißt wir haben momentan die
Voraussetzung jemand der sich für die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft entscheidet
der sollte möglichst sein
ursprungspass zurückgeben die
Staatsangehörigkeit das ist ja ein Punkt
der mit drin steckt und wir haben auch
jetzt schon kürzere Fristen nämlich wir
haben zum Beispiel eine
sechsjahresfrist wenn man besondere
Integrationsleistungen erbracht hat und
genau das ist auch unser ansinn dass wir
eine nachhaltige und gute Integration
wollen und eine bewusste Entscheidung
für die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
jetzt hat Frau Yüksel den deutschen und
den türkischen Pass und Hermann Suhr hat
den deutschen und den israelischen Pass
wenden Sie es besser wenn beide das
Abgeben mit ihren israelischen Beziehung
zur türkischen Pass abgeben würden als
die Frage wie rum geht man an wie rum
geht man an dieses Thema ran also nach
unserer Auffassung ist es so dass wir
den Grundsatz beibehalten wollen dass
man die
Staatsbürgerschaft des Herkunftslandes
abgeben muss trotzdem haben wir für
besondere härtefellen Ausnahmen im
Gesetz vorgesehen und das ist auch gut
so aber es ist eben ein Unterschied ob
ich mehr Staatlichkeit generell zulasse
das heißt ja vielleicht nicht nur zwei
sondern auch drei Pässe oder ob ich sage
das ist die Ausnahme von der Regel das
ist einfach eine sich andere
Herangehensweise an dieses Thema okay
also das ist ein Punkt den sie wichtig
finden Herr Fratzscher das geht ja auch
immer um die wirtschaftliche Perspektive
es wird ja gesagt wir müssen Deutschland
attraktiver machen wir brauchen
Fachkräfte weil wir alle so alt sind und
zu wenig Kinder bekommen haben also
inwieweit hilft so eine Initiative jetzt
eben diese Verkürzung der Frist und
vielleicht bei bestimmten Dingen auch
eine Vereinfachung hilft das auch gegen
den Fachkräftemangel
es ist ein wichtiges Element damit man
Menschen eine klare Perspektive gibt
denn wir stehen ja im globalen
Wettbewerb um Fachkräfte und Deutschland
war in der Vergangenheit zumindest für
Fachkräfte von außerhalb Europa nicht
sehr attraktiv weil wir eben die Hürden
sehr hochgelegt haben auch im letzten
Fachkräfte Zuwanderungsgesetz hat man
die würden so hochgesetzt gesagt sie
brauchen entweder den Arbeitsvertrag
oder sie müssen schon Deutsch sprechen
bevor sie nach Deutschland kommen und
damit haben wir ein riesiges Problem
Deutschland hat ein alter Gesellschaft
deswegen uns fünf Millionen beschäftigt
in den nächsten 10 Jahren wegfallen die
mehr in Rente gehen als junge Menschen
nachkommen und man muss auch noch mal
betonen wenn man sich die letzten 50 60
Jahre in Deutschland anschaut wer dieser
wirtschaftliche Wohlstand den wir heute
haben ohne Zuwanderung gar nicht möglich
gewesen gerade in 2010er Jahren
da haben wir eigentlich schon eine
schrumpfende Bevölkerung gehabt von der
Demographie her aber zwei oder drei
Millionen zwei bis drei Millionen
zusätzliche Arbeitsplätze schaffen
können weil wir sehr stark von
Zuwanderung garantiert haben und deshalb
ist das mit Zuwanderung eine gute
Einwanderungspolitik eine wichtige
Grundlage für den wirtschaftlichen
Wohlstand und mit der Demografie wird es
zunehmend wichtiger dass wir das Gut
managen und attraktiv bleiben für sie
machen Unterschied ob ich das jetzt auf
ob ich nach acht Jahren eingebürgert
werde oder wie Frau Lindholz sagt wenn
man sich ja gut integriert hat hat man
schon die Möglichkeit das nach sechs
Jahren zu machen man muss eben überlegen
was man den Menschen an Perspektive
bieten will und nochmals wir stehen im
Wettbewerbs machen viele andere Länder
sind offener sind willkommener als das
in Deutschland der Fall ist und aus das
was wir als wissenschaftlichen Studien
kennen ist eine klare Perspektive eben
auch das ist nicht nur das Bleiberecht
sondern auch die Staatsbürgerschaft ein
wichtiges Element worauf die Menschen
schauen sagen welches Land wo will ich
arbeiten beruflich mein
Lebensmittelpunkt finden und deshalb
sollte so eine Staatsbürgerschaft eben
nicht am Ende nicht unbedingt der
Integration kommt sondern sollte ein
Teil davon sein wenn man so ich habe
eben schon gesagt sie haben zwei Pässe
sind 2400 Deutschland gekommen warum
haben Sie sich dafür entschieden und wie
für die deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit und
wie schwierig ist es eigentlich
deutscher Staatsbürger zu werden nicht
so schwierig wenn man natürlich die
Faktoren sozusagen erfüllt also ich
verstehe Integration als eine Art von
Prozess diese Prozess braucht Zeit das
ist nicht nur also ich habe heute jetzt
bis jetzt mehrfach geholt gut integriert
aber keiner kann mir sagen was bedeutet
eigentlich gut integriert ist das nur
die Sprache ist dass er eine Arbeit zu
finden ist das nicht kriminell zu sein
oder geht es um was anderes und wenn wir
die Debatten die letzten Jahren
anschauen dann haben wir natürlich
großartige Beispiele wo Menschen
wirklich angekommen sind wo sie Teil
diese Gesellschaft geworden sind diese
Gesellschaft auch bereichern aber eben
auch Problemfälle vor allem wenn es um
materialische Strukturen um
Antisemitismus
Umgang mit Religion all diese Fälle um
sie
wirklich zu bearbeiten müssen wir ganz
klare Faktoren nennen was bedeutet
eigentlich gut integriert sein die
Menschen respektive geben wenn sie
ankommen auch emotional ankommen das ist
letztendlich am Ende dieser Prozess die
Staatsangehörigkeit da ist ob das fünf
oder sechs oder sieben Jahren ich kann
da jetzt nicht wirklich in Zahlen wo es
wirklich gut funktioniert aber nach 13
Jahren nach drei ich konnte natürlich
nach acht Jahren aber es war von mir zu
kompliziert das alles zu machen deshalb
habe ich gewartet und das ist auch enorm
wichtig das ist nicht entweder oder das
heißt die Menschen haben nach vier
Jahren wenn sie wirklich hier gearbeitet
haben die Sprache gelernt haben auch
eine unbefristete Offenheit die ihn auch
die Möglichkeit auch anzukommen in diese
Gesellschaft die Staatsbürgerschaft muss
immer die Spitze des Eisberges im
positiven Sinne Menschen die wirklich
angekommen sind die wirklich alles
erfüllt haben sollten das bekommen und
ich bin auch dafür dass wir endlich ein
globaler Welt ankommen und das bedeutet
auch Mehrstaatlichkeit muss erlaubt
werden
natürlich also vor allem in BI
nationaler eben wo die Kinder natürlich
in beiden Ländern sozusagen emotional
verbunden sind
muss man sich diese die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit in dem Sinne
sozusagen verdienen ist es wichtig dass
man ja dafür was leistet auch oder ist
es inzwischen gerade angesichts des
demografischen Wandels nicht vielleicht
auch so dass wir eigentlich sehr froh
sein können wenn Menschen gerne deutsche
werden wollen also zunächst mal sind wir
immer froh wenn Menschen zu uns kommen
und hier auch im Beitrag leisten für die
Gesellschaft und dem Arbeitsmarkt und
natürlich hat der fratcher Recht wenn er
sagt wir müssen schauen welche
Attraktivität unser Land für
Arbeitskräfte bietet und ich glaube da
ist es vielfältig von der Frage mit
welcher Geschwindigkeit bekommen wir das
hin bis zur Frage wenn jemand bei uns
ist wie wird der richtig integriert in
unser Land welche Rahmenbedingungen
findet er dann auch hier vor dass wir
als Land attraktiv sind und am Ende ist
es auch wichtig dass jemand die
Möglichkeit hat und das ist habe ich
jetzt schon der Fall die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit zu bekommen wir
haben auch diverse Ausnahme Tatbestände
wo wir zwei Staatsbürgerschaften
zulassen insbesondere bei Kindern die
auch in Deutschland geboren sind und
deswegen ist es kein Ausschlusskriterium
es sind 105.000 Syrer und man Beispiel
zu nennen hätten im letzten Jahr die
Möglichkeit gehabt zu sagen wir wollen
mit dem mit der Beschleunigung nicht
nach acht sondern nach sechs Jahren wenn
wir gut integriert sind die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten davon hat es
aber nur 100 haben das aber nur 5%
angenommen und das ist der Punkt wo ich
einfach sage wenn jemand schnell gut
integriert ist und gut integriert ist
eben mehr als eine Arbeitsstelle zu
haben gut integriert ist in der
Gesellschaft anzukommen gut integriert
ist besonders gute Sprachkenntnisse zu
haben ist sich ehrenamtlich zu
engagieren das alles sieht unser
einbürgerungsrecht schon vor dann hat
man die Möglichkeit das zu beschleunigen
und das ist unser Ansatz zu sagen
Anreize zu schaffen dass Menschen die
hier ankommen sich möglichst nachhaltig
zügig integrieren können und natürlich
auch am Ende die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen können ich
finde es ist aber schon auch eine Frage
ob man sich nicht auch einem
Loyalitätskonflikt mit seinem
Herkunftsland befinden kann frau Yüksel
warum ist es für Sie wichtig dass die
beide Staatsbürgerschaften haben also
man darf das nicht vergessen also ich
habe 1995 erst die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen das sind 25
Jahre nachdem ich in Deutschland war es
gab Kriterien die ich erfüllen müsste
das war zum Beispiel der Lebensunterhalt
als halbweise ging das nicht so schnell
den Lebensunterhalt sicherzustellen und
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig um
einfach das gibt einem Menschen in
Sicherheitsgefühl also ich bin seit 52
Jahren in Deutschland und immer noch
bekomme ich das zu spüren dass ich eben
nicht ein Teil dieser Gesellschaft bin
aber trotzdem geht doch eigentlich nicht
geht eigentlich nicht
bekommen oder auf der Straße
angesprochen werden sie können mich
nicht vertreten sie sind Ausländern sie
ihr Bundespräsident ist XY das wird uns
ja sogar in der letzten
Legislaturperiode von aus ihren Kreisen
wurde der Kollege aus den Grünen
mehrmals so angesprochen
das Argument doch viel stärker wenn sie
sagen würden nein ich bin Deutsche ich
habe den einen deutschen Pass und ich
habe ja auch den deutschen Pass als
andere gibt einem Jahr nur ein Gefühl es
ist also mit dem mit der Aufgabe des
passen also keiner sie wussten nicht
dass ich beide Pässe habe und wir kennen
uns seit 2013 es macht mit dem Menschen
nichts anderes aber wenn ich jemanden
zwinge seine Identität seine Herkunft
abzugeben dann ist man nicht schneller
integriert dich mal wir haben eben
darüber gesprochen sie haben gesagt sie
wollten es gar nicht abgeben weil ihnen
das wichtig war Deutscher zu werden wenn
sie ihre behalten dürfen aber wir sind
doch dann keine schlechteren deutschen
und ich glaube dass wir uns mit unserem
Land in identifizieren das ist auch der
Punkt gewesen warum ich deutsche
Staatsbürgerin wurde um in meinem Land
etwas zu bewegen eine Brücke
herzustellen und das mache ich seit über
30 Jahren und ich bin manchmal
verzweifelt wie wir Politikerin
Politiker mit diesen Themen umgehen und
Integration ist nicht seit gestern wir
sprechen über 60 Jahre alt
genau Integration was ist Integration
erklären Sie mir was das bedeutet
anzukommen integrations bedeutet ich
zweifel wenn ich dann ihre Integration
ich definiere das allgemein jetzt
Integration ist die Veränderung der
Werte das die Grundwerte die wir haben
integration bedeutet dass meine Tochter
ein selbstbestimmtes Leben haben darf
wenn sie das will das ist Integration
und da hakt es auch und das Gesetz und
die Erwartungen und die konkreten
Faktoren geben das nicht wieder ob
jemand integriert ist oder nicht es geht
nicht wieder also wir haben ja mit
klaren Kriminalität wir haben mit
Islamisten viel zu tun aber schon
deutscher geworden sind das heißt die
deutsche Pass ist auch nicht eine
Garantie dass diese Menschen wirklich
angekommen sind aber und da müssen wir
unsere Energie investieren man darf das
nicht miteinander vermischen nicht bitte
Sie also nein Integration also wenn wir
über Integration reden dann und die
Menschen sind integriert dann ist das
die Frage nach sechs oder acht nach fünf
Jahren als wenn man auf fünf Jahre
runtergehen passen wir uns den
europäischen Ländern an Sie haben es
hier eben gesagt aber nicht alle
europäische Länder haben viele und wir
wissen auch dass auch deutsche
Staatsbürger die im EU-Land sich die
zweite deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit des
EU-Landes hohen seit 2007 auch das
bearbeiten dürfen auch das ist neu aber
es gibt über 60 Prozent der Menschen die
die Mehrstaatlichkeit haben ihr Problem
ist nicht die Integration der Menschen
weil wir reden von acht auf fünf weil
acht gab es ja ihr Problem ist die
Mehrstaatlichkeit und da muss man mal
endlich mal drüber reden
ich habe kein Problem mit mehr
Staatlichkeit und ich habe auch kein
Problem mit fünf oder sechs Jahre mein
Problem ist sind die Kriterien erfüllt
dass man wirklich emotional angekommen
ist oder machen wir es uns einfach und
geben diesen Bass der wirklich ein ein
großartige
Geschenk für die Menschen die dazu
gekommen so erlebe ich das so habe ich
das 2017 auch emotional erlebt Menschen
die das nicht verdient haben
darüber will ich mit ihnen reden
ist sie wollen ist auf 35 Jahre
reduzieren man kann natürlich auf der
einen Seite sagen ist es Zeitfenster
jetzt so entscheidend sind sechs sind
sieben sind acht Jahre aber ich glaube
doch ist dass wir es ein gewisser
Zeitraum sein sollte und ich halte
persönlich zum Beispiel drei Jahre für
ein sehr kurzen Zeitraum der Beurteilung
ob sich jemand wirklich in unser Land
nachhaltig integriert hat auch mit
unserer demokratischen Wertevorstellung
identifiziert und das ist übrigens auch
der Unterschied warum man in das in der
Europäischen Union die
doppelstaatlichkeit zulässt seit 2007
weil es einfach in der Europäischen
Union als gemeinsame Werteordnung hier
ein commitment gibt und das ist eben der
Unterschied aber wir nehmen Sie mal ein
autokratisches Land wie China ich sag
eben wenn jemand der aus China nach
Deutschland kommt ihr seit drei oder
vier Jahren arbeitet unter dann die
Möglichkeit hat die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft nach dem was Sie sich
vorstellen zu erhalten habe ich
persönlich mein Problem zum einen
Zeitfenster und auch zum zweiten dass er
aus dass ich aus zwei vollkommen
unterschiedlichen politischen Systemen
komme ich würde ganz gerne mal eben weil
sie Europa ja erwähnt haben in dem
Vergleich zu anderen europäischen
Ländern steht Deutschland ziemlich weit
hinten im was die Zahl der Einbürgerung
betrifft bei uns werden 2021 hat
Schweden 8,6 Prozent der Ausländer
eingegebürgert in Deutschland war das
nur 1,1% Herr frischer wie stark ist das
auch innerhalb der EU wenn ich mich
jetzt umschaue als Fachkraft überlegen
wo gehe ich hin also was ist das für ein
Signal wenn so wenig Menschen
eingebürgert werden
ist kein gutes Signal wir nochmals wir
stehen im Wettbewerb um die klügsten
Köpfe oder höchste Köpfe klug ist jetzt
falsch Begriff um Menschen die eine
Zukunft suchen eine Perspektive suchen
sich einbringen wollen und wir müssen
eben sehr genau überlegen
wie können wir als Land attraktiv sein
wir haben Recht der deutsche Pass ist
ein Geschenk aber es ist eben auch etwas
anderes ist auch ein Geschenken Gewinn
für Deutschland die Hinsicht wenn
Menschen sagen ich möchte in Deutschland
mein Lebensmittelpunkt haben wenn ich
einen Punkt ergänzen darf wenn Sie sich
anschauen wann die einbildungszahlen
Deutschland sehr hoch waren war das in
den 90er Jahren wenn sie sogenannten
Aussiedler kamen und die haben sehr
schnell den Pass erhalten und da kann
man sich sehr wohl fragen ist der Grund
für die Diskussion die wir heute haben
nicht viel mehr darin dass viele in den
Diskurs noch deutsch sein anders
definieren mehr über Herkunft als überwo
der Lebensmittelpunkt ist ich glaube das
ist meine Gefühle wichtiger
wichtiger wichtiger Punkt und ich glaube
wir müssen wir haben die Realität dass
sehr viele auch so wie sie beiden
mehrere Kulturen von der Herkunft her
haben oder in der Familie haben und das
gehört ja auch zu einer Perspektive zu
einer toleranten Gesellschaft dazu diese
Vielfalt zu akzeptieren und wenn wir
attraktiv für Menschen weltweit sein
wollen müssen wir ein hohes Maß an
Akzeptanz auch von Vielfalt haben und
dazu gehört eben auch Teil von mehreren
Kulturen in der eigenen Person zu leben
wenn Sie jetzt die Einwände der von der
cdu/csu-seite sind ist das wird da zu
wenig Vielfalt akzeptiert oder wie wird
das beurteilen
man muss nüchtern doch sagen die
Bemühungen der letzten Jahre beim beim
bei der Zuwanderung ist gescheitert und
zu Fachkräfte Zuwanderungsgesetz der
vorherigen Regierung sehen wir das
Menschen aus aus Drittländern so gut wie
nicht nach Deutschland kommen weil sie
sagen die Hürden sind zu hoch die
Perspektiven sind zu unklar es ist zu
unattraktiv nach Deutschland zu gehen da
müssen wir als Deutsche doch sagen was
müssen wir besser machen damit wir
attraktiver werden und dazu gehört
Offenheit Toleranz Akzeptanz ich tue
mich auch schwer mit dem Begriff
Integration Integration kann nicht
Assimilation heißen sondern muss auch
Wertschätzung der Vielfalt bedeuten klar
reden über Werte Akzeptanz der
Demokratie an Akzeptanz des
Grundgesetzes sind wichtige Kriterien
aber letztendlich müssen wir uns öffnen
attraktiver werden weil ansonsten
natürlich auch viele Migranten hierher
kommen viele Flüchtlinge die hierher
kommen die vielleicht noch nicht so
qualifizierte das ist ja ein Punkt wo
viele Leute sagen das wird nicht
funktionieren ja auch bei der Zuwendung
ich glaube wir müssen viel mehr auch
denken es geht kann ja nicht sein dass
wir fertige Geschäfte bekommen sagen
jetzt müsst ihr dies machen sondern
letztlich müssen wir auch überlegen wir
müssen in die Menschen investieren und
eigentlich aus einer rein ökonomischen
Perspektive es ist toll wenn die
Menschen jung sind wenn sie kommen weil
sie sie dann hier ausbilden können
qualifizieren können weil sie eine
Perspektive haben und deshalb sehe ich
das sehr kritisch also auch geflüchtete
die sich die hier in der Ausbildung
machen wieso soll nicht die die
Möglichkeit haben hier zu bleiben und
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
das ist nicht ausgeschlossen und was
natürlich immer ein Problem ist wenn man
jetzt alles so in einen Topf schmeißt ja
wenn ich jetzt mal nach Schweden schaue
und wir reden von Einwanderungspolitik
dann sind die Schweden gerade wegen
ihrer liberalen Einwanderungspolitik auf
einem anderen Kurs weil sie eben
feststellen dass sie fahren ihre
liberale Einwanderungspolitik und haben
sie zurückgefahren auch was die Aufnahme
an Migranten angeht deswegen ist es auch
nicht gut das immer alles in einen Topf
zu schmeißen wenn die hier Thema
Fachkräfte Einwanderung sehe dann wissen
sie dass wir das Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz beschlossen haben
dann kam Corona das eine Auswertung
dieses Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
ist eigentlich noch aus geht dass wir
gerade auch Geringqualifizierten
Menschen die Möglichkeit mit diesem
Gesetz geben nach Deutschland zu kommen
dass wir Menschen die Möglichkeit geben
hier erst nach einer Arbeitsstelle in
Deutschland zu suchen dass da sehr viel
passiert ist aber dass das noch nicht
evaluieren konnten dass man das noch
nicht evaluieren konnte und wenn man
immer mit dem Argument von
Arbeitsplätzen und Wirtschaft versucht
im Grunde genommen alles zu begründen
dann muss ich auch muss ich dir mir die
Frage stellen Arbeitsplätze sind wichtig
aber wichtig ist auch welche
Anforderungen ein Staat hat an einen
Bürger von dem er sagt du bekommst die
Staatsbürgerschaft mit allen Rechten und
Pflichten sind lebenslange Rechte auch
die damit verbunden sind und da kommt
der da für mich der Aspekt dazu dass das
aus mehr besteht als nur nur auf den
Arbeitsmarkt zu schauen
weil sie immer auch Schweden nehmen es
gibt Länder die sind restriktiver als
wir in Österreich muss man zehn Jahre im
Land gewesen sein und was mir von dieser
Bundesregierung fehlt ist tatsächlich
mal die Bestandsaufnahme an welcher
Stelle bevor man mit so einem Thema in
eine Ampel unabgestimmt an die
Öffentlichkeit geht die FDP widerspricht
dem Vorhaben und damit wieder Menschen
auch in unserem Land verunsichert zu
erklären an welcher Stelle und an
welchen Punkt die Änderungen tatsächlich
zur Verbesserung in unserem Land führen
und das fehlt mir komplett darüber ist
überhaupt nicht gesprochen worden das
ist quasi einfach so also
bei den USA ist es übrigens muss man für
den Erhalt einer Greencard 5 Jahre im
Land gewesen sein und da reicht das für
die Grien
Entschuldigung nein Entschuldigung für
den Erhalt eines us-passes muss ein
Greencard Inhaber ich habe falsch gesagt
fünf Jahre da gewesen sein 30 Monate am
reichen auch schon
drei Bemerkungen erstmal ist stört mich
immer wieder dass wir das Thema
moralisieren darstellen und das auf
einmal die andere Seite mit ihrer
Argumentation komplett der legitimiert
wird als unmodern oder sogar kommt
feindlich oder Sie wollen Kulturen und
so weiter nicht akzeptieren das will ich
hier nicht haben und das finde ich
unangebracht zweitens wir haben nicht
die beiden attraktivsten oder drei
attraktivsten Ländern der Welt wo die
meisten Menschen vor allem aus den Nahen
Osten hingehen wollen das ist USA
Australien und Kanada und die haben ja
kurzer Zeiten wenn die Leute angekommen
sind aber damit jemand ankommt das heißt
das Visum bekommt überhaupt Eingreifen
zu dürfen gibt's ganz ganz krasser
Selektionen und Erwartungen und Faktoren
die man erfüllen muss und wenn sie dann
da sind das haben wir gar nicht wir
erwarten dass die Leute bis bis die
Grenze zu uns kommen und dann wurden wir
wie irgendwie integrieren das heißt
Asylbewerber die von Krieg
führten hier kommen sollten andere Wege
finden auch in der Arbeitsmarkt ja aber
wir sollten alles tun da bin ich absolut
bei Ihnen dass wir alles tun um
diejenigen zu holen von den Herkunft
Ländern die wir brauchen ob
geringqualifiziert ob hochqualifiziert
wir brauchen diese Menschen wir können
ihn Perspektive geben indem wir
Integration definieren ich will das
nicht aufgeben ich weiß das SPD und
Linke teilweise von Teilhabe sprechen
weil sie die Verantwortung auf die
Mehrheitsgesellschaft liegen ja
integration bedeutet auch eine gewisse
Bringschuld der Zugewanderten und da
geht's nicht darum Kultur und Tradition
aufzugeben sondern die Grundwerte diese
Gesellschaft zu akzeptieren und da haben
wir Nachholbedarf
sie wollten dazu also
wir reden hier von Integration und dann
würde ich auch noch mal die Frage
stellen also sie sagen sechs drei Jahre
fünf Jahre sind zu wenig aber ihr
Problem ist trotzdem noch die
mehrstatigkeit das ist das Problem da
würde ich gerne mal wissen wo dran sie
das Festmachen dass das schädliches für
unser Land und Integration wenn man
sechs acht Jahre nehmen wir auch immer
ist ja das Problem was sie nennen das
kriminelle deutsche Staatsbürger sind
nicht behoben also das ist ja damit
nicht behoben wir können das ja gar
nicht dran festmachen wir können auch 10
Jahre machen und die Menschen sind nach
10 Jahren kriminell also das wird mit
dieser Integration Debatte die wir hier
führen nicht behoben werden zu dem
anderen
Kriterien die wir erfüllen aber wenn sie
jemand wie sie sie sind jetzt deutscher
Staatsbürger und nächstes Jahr werden
sie kriminell muss ich sie dann wieder
ausbürger das ist ja die Frage von den
Menschen die zu uns kommen wenn ich
merke dass jemand zum Beispiel nicht in
diese Gesellschaft angekommen dann muss
ich ihn nicht belohnen mit einem
deutschen Staatsbürger doch weil es gibt
keine keine Begrenzung es gibt keine
Definitionen für Desintegration sondern
es geht nur um Geld machen wir wollen
sie Integration definieren ich lebe seit
1970 hier ich bin 95 als eingebürgert
worden wann wo dran machen Sie fest wie
die wo Integration funktioniert ich habe
Familienangehörigen die so lange hier
leben meine Mama z.B hat die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft nicht weil sie sagt
ich möchte die Türkisch nicht abgeben
weil ich gerne in der Türkei neben
deinem Papa beerdigt werden will
Staatsbürgerschaft integriert wird was
also ich finde dieses Wort Integration
wirklich furchtbar weil ich nicht weiß
ja wie wollen Sie das Definieren
also stimmt die kriterin
gemeinsam
eigentlich wir können auch gucken wie
die Leute eigentlich mit dem Test TV
machen mit der Verhalten die sie zeigen
und so weiter und dann gibt viele
Möglichkeiten aber das ändert doch an
diese Menschen nicht ich gerne diese 31
Fragen oder 310 sind das davon muss ich
31 sagen
so man kommt doch man kommt aber auch
zum Gespräch wir haben zum Beispiel
den Passus mit der Einordnung in die
deutschen Lebensverhältnisse ins Gesetz
reingeschrieben weil man damit die mehr
Ehe als
Ausschlusskriterium drin hatte dass
jemand der nicht mehrfach verheiratet
ist am Ende noch die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten kann dieser
Passus wird rausgestrichen da würde mich
interessieren aber das ändert ja
trotzdem
Kriterien schon definiert und zwar
letztes Jahr mit dem Antisemitismus also
Menschen die sich antisemitisch aussahen
oder Verhaltensweisen werden nicht
eingebürgert das ist schon ein Anfang
das bedeutet es ist machbar das
irgendwie zu messen genau
sein derjenigen die gerne den deutschen
Pass haben möchten also die bringt
schuld ist glaube ich bei vielen
Menschen die ich kenne die ich in den
Integrationspolitik die ich gemacht habe
ist gegeben die Menschen fühlen sich
einfach nicht mitgenommen weil sie eben
ihre zweiten Pass in diesem Fall
türkische oder ihre abgeben müssen weil
sie sagen das ändert mich doch nicht ich
bleibe doch der Mensch so wie ich bin
warum macht man das bei mir und bei
einem EU-Bürger nicht ich mache mal ein
ganz kleines Beispiel ich lebe ich habe
95 das 98 das erste Mal wählen dürfen da
war ich 35 das muss man sich mal
überlegen ich lebe dort darf an keiner
Wahl teilnehmen ein EU-Bürger der seit
drei Monaten in der Kommune lebt darf
wählen dann erklären Sie mir da den
Unterschied wo da die Integration
funktioniert ich bin integriert ich will
was für mein Land für meine Stadt tun
und deswegen bin ich auch in der Politik
dass ich mal hier im Deutschen Bundestag
sitzen und für mein Land Politik machen
darf das war nicht mein Ziel ich wollte
in der Kommune versuchen etwas zu
verändern weil diese Debatten die wir
seit Jahren führen wo wir Verantwortung
haben in der Politik das ist wirklich
beschämen und das Schmerz wenn wir diese
Debatten sehen also das ist nicht schön
oder auch ihre Eltern da tatsächlich
sich immer noch ausgeschlossen fühlen
teilweise ja aber man muss einfach noch
mal schauen wo kommen wir her ich habe
vorhin schon mal den Unterschied
versucht zu erklären die Europäische
Union ist eine gemeinsame
Wertegemeinschaft da hat man sich darauf
verständigt die doppelstaatlichkeit
zuzulassen wir lassen es auch einen
besonderen Ausnahmen Fällen zu wenn
einem in einem Land einen besonderes ein
besonderer Nachteil droht oder wenn das
Land ein gar nicht aus der
Staatsbürgerschaft entlässt aber wie
beantworten Sie zum Beispiel die Frage
dass ein junger Mann oder ein
mittelaltermann zwei
Staatsbürgerschaften hat und dann für
das andere Land dessen
Staatsbürgerschaft der auch besitzt in
den Krieg einzieht wollen wir das zum
Beispiel akzeptieren das ist auch eine
Frage die beantwortet werden muss es
gibt Rechtsverhältnisse ich gehe zum
Familienrecht über die Frage wird da
auch sein
ganz einfach bei familienrechtlichen
Problemstellungen wieder eheschaltung
ist in Europa alles vereinheitlich das
ist ein anderen Ländern nicht der Fall
auch diese Fragen müssen beantwortet
werden
die meisten is Kämpfer die wirklich vor
ein andere Terrororganisation gekämpft
haben waren deutsche Staatsbürger ja
also das ist aber diese Argumente von
gestern also wir können auf andere
wissen dass das nicht gestattet ist aber
der Punkt ist sie müssen diese Fragen
beantworten und Mehrstaatlichkeit
bedeutet eben es ist dann nicht nur
beschränkt auf zwei was ist denn
vielleicht auch dort vielleicht ist auch
noch eine dritte dabei und die Frage
muss man beantworten ob man es zum
Grundsatz oder zur Ausnahme macht aber
warum warum ist das so ein Problem ist
ich verstehe es immer noch nicht warum
ist es so ein Problem wenn also die
Tochter von Herrn Mansour die hat jetzt
einfach auch zwei Pässe warum ist das
ein Problem oder weil nach unserer
Auffassung ist ein Unterschied macht ob
ich im Prinzip sage ich gebe die
Staatsbürgerschaft meines
Herkunftslandes auf und sage ich möchte
Staatsbürger dieses Landes sein weil sie
haben das vorhin dargestellt es ist mehr
als die Frage wo bin ich wo werde ich
beerdigt es ist mehr als die Frage
wo wo er mich oder er mich nicht so ist
die Frage ist sondern die Frage wie
identifiziere ich mich mit dem Land
dessen zukünftige Rechte und Pflichten
sozusagen für mein ganzes Leben gelten
und
die Werte genau diese
Integrationsdebatte und nicht an die
Recht an zwei oder drei
Staatsangehörigkeit ich kenne ganz viele
Leute die zwei haben und in Deutschland
nie emotional angekommen und ich kenne
Leute die drei haben und großartige
Demokraten geworden sind also für diesen
Kampf glaube ich wäre besser wenn die
Union diese Debatte von gestern aufgibt
in den Zukunft ankommt und dann ihre
Energie investiert indem sie sagt wir
müssen Integration besser definieren wir
müssen die Werte besser vermitteln wir
mussten die Leute ganz klar sagen
Desintegration wird bestraft Integration
ich glaube man kann das eine und das
andere man muss es nicht verbinden man
kann unterschiedliche Auffassung sein
Integration der gebe ich Ihnen Recht
muss in jedem Fall gewährleistet sein
für jeden der bei uns ankommt mit oder
ohne Staatsbürgerschaft man kann bei dem
Thema doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
geteilter Meinung sein das ist auch
vollkommen in Ordnung so trotzdem ist es
für uns ein Unterschied ob es der
generelle Fall ist oder ob es eben die
Ausnahmeregelung ist aus meiner Sicht
nichts mit der Frage zu tun ob jemand
sich in unser Land nachhaltig gut
integrieren sollte das gilt für beide
wenn Sie das diese Diskussion über
Integration
befinden sie das dass diese Diskussion
wo es letztendlich wo man sagt es geht
Verkürzung von acht auf fünf ist es ja
nicht ein völlig andere Diskussion dass
die doch so viel Emotionen und so viel
grundsätzlich ist wieder auslöst was
heißt das was bedeutet das über ja den
Stand Deutschlands als Einwanderungsland
für mich zeigt es dass wir doch immer
noch sehr starke nationalen Grenzen
denken und so die die Tatsache auch dass
wir eine multikulturelles Land sind mit
vielen Menschen mit wir haben vier über
vier Millionen Muslime in Deutschland
ist das Thema Islam ist Teil von
Deutschland nicht wieder aufmachen das
wurde ja schon häufig genug gesagt würde
und aber das ist eben ein Teil und zu
realisieren diese kulturelle Vielfalt
ist Teil von Deutschland wir haben weit
über fast ein fast jeder vierte Mensch
der in Deutschland lebt hat
eine Migrationsgeschichte hat irgendwo
kulturelle Verbindung zu anderen Ländern
und ich stimme zu wenn man Deutscher ist
oder deutsche ist dann hat man Rechte
und Pflichten aber ich stehe für sie
stehen Widerspruch nicht dass man nicht
das auch recht und Pflicht in einem
anderen Land hat wo man sich an Regeln
hält wenn man dort ist und wählen kann
in zwei Ländern wählen das muss man dann
auch dazu sagen
nur ganz kurz erstmal Vielfalt ist nicht
zelebrieren von Unterschiede sondern
auch die Festlegung von Regeln also ja
wir sind ein vielfältiger Gesellschaft
das ist die Realität
natürlich für alle habe ich nicht gesagt
das ist Vielfalt bedeutet auch deutscher
nicht nur Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund zweitens
wir müssen einfach die Realität ins Auge
schauen und sagen wie können wir besser
attraktiv für diejenigen die vielleicht
angeworben werden von anderen Ländern
und da glaube ich können wir sein wenn
wir ganz andere Strategie da geht's
nicht um Staatsangehörigkeit und
deutscher passt das spielt überhaupt
keine Rolle sondern wir müssen die Leute
ermöglichen anzukommen mit der Sprache
mit der arbeitsfindung mit der
wohnungsbindung in Berlin
ein großes Problem dass Deutsch ist eine
schwierige Sprache es gibt Länder die
sind Mitbewerber wo man mit Englisch
irgendwie ganz gut zurechtkommen kann
also wenn man jetzt aus der
wirtschaftlichen Situation Perspektive
schaut ist das nicht ein viel größeres
Problem
ja wir sehen unser wissenschaftlichen
Studien das muss ich wieder vorliestamm
mit dem Begriff Integration aber
angekommen zu sein das ist im Prinzip
zwei große Faktoren eine Rolle spielen
einmal habe ich Arbeit habe ich einen
auskommen habe ich eine Aufgabe und das
andere ist Sprache und soziale Kontakte
daher ist Sprache extrem wichtig gar
keine Frage aber deshalb haben wir auch
ein wettbewerbsnatter Gegenüber
englischsprachigen Ländern weil die
meisten können das ist eine leichtere
Sprache auch da müssen wir überlegen
wenn wir Menschen wenn wir attraktiv
sein wollen müssen wir dort eine gewisse
Flexibilität zeigen und sagen es muss
nicht jeder fließen Deutsch sprechen
wenn er nach Deutschland nach
Deutschland kommt und hier arbeitet
bekommt
eine gewisse Offenheit gewisse
Flexibilität haben ich komme noch mal
aufs Fachkräfte zueinander ins Gesetz
wenn sie ohne Arbeitsvertrag nach
Deutschland kommen wollen müssen sie
sprachkennt vorweisen können und das ist
für viele einfache Hürde und da müssen
wir flexibler werden in Deutschland und
sagen wir wollen uns öffnen Menschen die
auch kein Deutsch erreichen können nach
Deutschland kommen können hier arbeiten
müssen natürlich Deutsch lernen klar
wenn wenn wir bei einem Einbürgerung
sprechen dann ist ja klar dann muss
diese Sprache einigermaßen beherrscht
werden aber wir müssen mehr flexibler
sein also wir müssen als Gesellschaft
auch mehr in die Menschen investieren
also es ist ein geben und nehmen das ist
nicht nur ein Geben von einer Seite zu
sagen ihr müsst euch integrieren sondern
wir müssen eben auch als Gesellschaft
die Chance zu öffnen dass diese Menschen
das können also da möchte ich gerne noch
mal was ich bin ja bei Ihnen wenn die
Menschen habe ich vorhin auch gesagt
wenn man hier ist dass man anknüpft nach
schaut dass sie vernünftig integriert
werden was Sprache Gesellschaft angeht
wir haben versucht aus der Europäischen
Union in der Vergangenheit auch
Fachkräfte nach Deutschland zu bekommen
wir haben versucht junge Menschen nach
Deutschland zu bekommen damit die hier
eine Ausbildung machen damit die unseren
Arbeitsmarkt unterstützen da war genau
der Sprache das Thema viele sind nämlich
wieder zurückgegangen zurückgegangen
weil sie mit der Sprache nicht zurecht
gekommen sind und deswegen bin ich schon
der Auffassung wenn jemand nach
Deutschland kommen möchte um hier zu
arbeiten
die Grundkenntnisse der Sprache da sein
müssen dass wir dann hier noch
investieren zum Beispiel die
Krankenschwester die kommt aber dass
jemand mit null Deutschkenntnissen nach
Deutschland kommt bei den Erfahrungen
die wir hier in der Vergangenheit
gemacht haben und wir wollen erreichen
dass er hier bleibt das halte ich
persönlich nicht für zielführend aber
zum Beispiel die der gesunde ehemalige
Gesundheitsminister
sehr lange hat doch gesucht in Mexiko
und Philippinen und Leute
pflegepersonalschwestern
das sind spezielle anwerbeprogramme wo
man dort schon vor Ort für eine
bestimmte qualifizierte gibt's ja immer
noch wo man für eine bestimmte
Qualifizierung sorgt dann ist aber
sichergestellt dass Sie hier an ich
nenne man Krankenhaus bei mir in der
Region kommt dort dann auch ich nenne
das wirklich aufgefangen begleitet
werden wo all die Sachen die man braucht
Wohnung arbeitsprache soziale Anbindung
das wird alles
gesteuert das wird alles organisiert
und auf dem Weg kann man das machen aber
dass man jemandem im Prinzip ohne die
Rahmenbedingungen festzulegen und die
sind nicht festgelegt dann sagt du
kannst hierher kommen auch wenn du die
deutsche Sprache nicht besitzt und muss
damit erst hier anfangen und suchst ohne
Sprache hier auch noch ein Ausbildungs-
oder Arbeitsplatz das funktioniert nicht
weil das Elli haben wir erlebt die
Erfahrung aus der Vergangenheit haben
wir es fehlt genau an es braucht mehr
solche gezielten an Werbeprogramme da
ist auch die Wirtschaft das sind die
Handwerkskammer die IHKs gefordert wenn
ich die Menschen halten will ist es mehr
als sie eben nur hierher zu holen
es gibt viele
extrem erfolgreiche multilaterale
Unternehmen die in Deutschland
mittlerweile Englisch als ihre
Arbeitssprache haben weil sie sagen sie
wollen attraktiv sein für die klügsten
Köpfe gucken sich die großen künstlerne
Microsoft in Deutschland riesiger
Konzern erfolgreich die würden es gar
nicht schaffen nur deutschsprachige
Beschäftigte Sachen und deshalb diese
dieser Gedanke wir müssen jetzt die
Hürde so hochsetzen die Menschen müssen
sie haben gesagt die Leute müssen dürfen
nicht ohne deutschsprachige Kinder nach
Deutschland kommen ganz hoch
qualifizierten
Punkt zu Ende machen ich finde ja ganz
vorsichtig sein mit dem ganz hoch
qualifiziert also wir müssen wir
brauchen Arbeitskräfte Fachkräfte in
allen Bereichen hoch für qualifizierte
wir brauchen Leute in der Gastronomie
wenn man sie in der Pflege anschauen
auch hochqualifiziert aber nicht
besonders gut bezahlt also wir dürfen
müssen da sehr vorsichtig sein nicht zu
sagen nur gewisse Menschen dürfen wir
haben wollen also wir müssen offen sein
wir müssen flexibel sein und wenn wir
die Hürden zu hochlegen auch bei den
Sprachkenntnissen glaube ich dann werden
wir scheitern
Sprachen ist recht nicht bei den Berufen
von denen sie gerade gesprochen haben
und gerade in der IT-Branche wissen sie
auch dass uns da nicht die deutsche
Sprache notwendig ist sondern dass man
dass die englische Sprache möglich ist
wir haben mit dem fachkräftigen
Einwanderungsgesetz genau beim Thema
Sprache einiges gemacht also es muss man
dann schon korrekt darstellen und darf
nicht alle Berufssparten immer in einen
Topf schmeißen aber es wäre dann nicht
um Bayern verteidigen zu wollen muss ich
sagen meine Arbeit mit den ähm mit den
Menschen die zu uns gekommen sind vor
allem in willkommen Klassen Bayern
investiert enorm groß und die
Sprachkenntnisse in Bayern sind viel
besser als an anderen Bundesländern das
ist auch weil sie auch Forderungen
stellen und nicht nur mit den Leuten
kuscheln wollen aber das ist ein anderes
Thema alles nur alles nur also das ist
Fachkräfte da bin ich absolut bei ihnen
wir reden hier aber über
Staatsangehörigkeit
würde ich gerne ganz kurz Frau Lindenhof
sie sagten ja eben die mehrtatigkeit
wenn man die hat dann kann man zweimal
wählen man kann dann
also diese diese Debatten diese
neidfaktoren die man dann immer wieder
in Innenraum wirft finde ich einfach
wirklich nicht schön wir haben über 60
Prozent der Menschen die die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben die machen das
und wenn sie dann speziell die
türkischen weil ich ja aus der Türkei
komme ich habe es mit 35 das erste Mal
wählen dürfen ich durfte in der Türkei
nicht fehlen das Gesetz also das ist
jetzt erst neu dass Menschen die hier
leben auch in ihrem Heimatland wählen
dürfen wissen Sie was das mit den
Menschen macht die hier 20 30 40 Jahre
leben und ihrem Leben noch nie gewählt
haben in Deutschland nicht auch in ihrem
Heimatland nicht und das betraf viele
türkische Mitbürger Mitbürger die jetzt
ich glaube seit 10 15 Jahren erst wählen
dürfen und das bei den Konsulaten also
ich würde einfach überlegen wenn wir
darüber diskutieren dass man das nicht
miteinander aber warum können
warum hat es bei ihnen so lange gedauert
dass sie dann oder auch bei ihren Eltern
dass sie sie wollen Deutsch wir haben
ihre Mutter ist noch Türkin oder ist
auch ist nicht deutsche also warum gibt
es dann auch so eine ja so eine
Zurückhaltung dass man nicht vielleicht
früher sagt ich würde gerne Deutsch
werden und ich möchte hier auch wählen
ich möchte mich auch wählen lassen
können also ich habe mich sehr früh
engagiert ehrenamtlich habe versucht
immer Menschen zu helfen ich habe 1980
leider mein Papa verloren der ist
tödlich verunglückt und das war so der
Punkt wo ich dann also mich noch mehr in
in diese politische Arbeit geworfen habe
nur wenn sie halbweise in Rente bekommen
haben sie die Lebensunterhalt nicht
sichergestellt ich habe dann irgendwann
angefangen eine Ausbildung zu machen
auch das reicht nicht also es brauchte
eine Zeit um mein Leben zu Unterhalt
selber sicherzustellen damit ich die
Einbürgerung beantragen kann und das
habe ich dann erst gemacht nachdem ich
verheiratet war mit meinem Mann und
unseren beiden Kindern die waren dann
auch schon da das Problem war dass ich
mit also das würde in die Tiefe gehen
aber es gibt ja eine bestimmte
Zurückhaltung auch Deutsch zu werden
deshalb weil eben die sie die ihre
eigene Identität abgeben müssen und
solange man an in einem Land also sie
erwarten jetzt mit wenn das einfacher
wird erwarten sie sozusagen auch dann
mit wenn das jetzt einfach erwarten sie
da so wirklich so ein Schub dass sich
dann wirklich viel mehr Leute einbürgern
lassen ich glaube viele Menschen die
schon seit langem hier leben würden das
machen weil sie einfach sich dann auch
angenommen fühlen das Gefühl ein Teil
dieser Gesellschaft zu sein ist leider
nicht in unserem Land gegeben das merke
ich in den Debatten im Parlament das
merke ich in Diskussion die heute Abend
und wenn sie morgens die Zeitungs auf
Zeitung aufschlagen sehen Sie das auch
und diese Menschen werden immer mehr er
zurückgezogen zurückgedrängt und ich
glaube das ist unsere Aufgabe diese
Menschen abzuholen die einen Teil dieser
Gesellschaft sind die sich zu unseren
Werten bekennen die müssen wir wieder zu
uns aufnehmen ich bin absolut bei ihnen
ich bin auch dafür dass man dass man das
schnell macht die haben das Recht
Deutsch zu sein für engagieren sich die
sind Teil dieser Gesellschaft und zwar
nicht nur seit 95 und auch vorher
nächstes Jahr haben wir aber Präsidenten
in der Türkei und was machen wir mit 40
Prozent Menschen die in Deutschland
leben und Erdogan als ihr Präsidenten
wählen da können wir auch eine Debatte
dazu führen sie ist absolut notwendig
dass Menschen die sehr sehr lange bei
uns sind immer noch nicht in eine
demokratische Gesellschaft angekommen
sind und das ist genau das Problem was
ich eben meinte diese Menschen haben von
Erdogan von der Türkei das Gefühl
bekommen dass sie einen Teil ein
Menschen sind dass sie auch das
Wahlrecht bekam die diese Menschen haben
vorher nicht gewählt und deswegen gehen
sie und Willen dort und das sind viele
die die türkische Staatsbürgerschaft
haben die gehen dort wählen es sind auch
doppelstapler dabei aber es gibt ja
es gibt ja zahlen das eben viele
Menschen die beide Pässe haben eben an
diesen Wahlen nicht teilnehmen und
deswegen müssen wir es schaffen diese
Menschen als ein Teil unserer
Gesellschaft zu sehen Sie
als was wäre das was positives wenn mehr
Menschen also gerade auch aus der
türkischen Community die sich dass die
sich einbürgern würden wenn sie das gut
also zunächst mal will ich erstmal sagen
es ist nicht gut
wenn man immer mit Vorwürfen agiert was
sie auch gerade wieder gemacht haben
weil meine andere Sichtweise hat ich
möchte noch mal sagen sie haben das
Beispiel mit dem doppelt wählen können
in der Türkei und in Deutschland jetzt
gerade selber auch angesprochen ja es
wäre besser man es wäre gut man kann die
Menschen nachhaltig in Deutschland
integrieren da kann man aber zwei
Überlegungen haben und das muss auch
gestattet diese zwei Überlegung zu haben
ist jemand der seine Staatsbürgerschaft
abgibt nicht jemand der wirklich sagt
ich wende mich ganz auch was das Thema
Wahlen angeht meinem neuen Land zu indem
ich die Staatsbürgerschaft bekomme und
ist das nicht auch in dem Moment ein
Bekenntnis in dem ich eben sage jetzt
bin ich Staatsbürger dieses Landes jetzt
nehme ich an den demokratischen Wahlen
dieses Landes teil ich habe nicht mehr
die Möglichkeit doppelt zu wählen außer
ich bin außer ich habe die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft weil ich über diese
Ausnahmeregeln
und es ist auch egal wo die Person sich
dann in Zukunft aufhalten mit zwei
Pässen sie werden immer auch die
Möglichkeit haben an Wahlen teilzunehmen
da kann man sagen man will das aber
wahrscheinlich
sagen wenn jemand lange nicht mehr in
Deutschland gelebt hat aber was nicht
mehr in Deutschland lebt aber noch
Deutscher ist der wählt der wählt dann
ist sie normal sind eigentlich bemängeln
dass die türkischen Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger Erdogan wählen weil im Moment
am Ende dieser Sendung deshalb muss ich
jetzt leider die Diskussion unterbrechen
ich würde sagen wir setzen das noch mal
irgendwann fort merke da ist noch Musik
drin und das
einwanderungs-bürgerungsgesetz das neue
ist ja auch noch nicht okay vielen dank
für diese Diskussion vielen dank ihnen
fürs Interesse morgen Fragen wird
Twitter Facebook Google wie mächtig sind
Elon Musk und Co also schalten Sie einen
würde uns freuen jetzt geht's weiter bei
Phoenix der Tag bis dann tschüss
[Musik]